immaginate
se domani
i vostri corpi
rigorosamente nudi
si trovassero sui cellulari di chiunque
la sentite l'ansia
il panico che risale l'esofago la paura
la famiglia il lavoro la società Che ne
sarà di me la sentita quest'ansia ecco
a me è successo
Se sei donna questo può succederti
immaginate ora di provare amore per
qualcuno
solo che ogni tanto ecco questa persona
vi ha dato le botte ma niente di serio
eh una cosetta
vi trovate nella stessa stanza
vi chiedo di fare sesso
e fa da quel punto
dite sì o diventate assassine e
assassini dite sì facciamolo perché
finisca presto o vi difendete
e come è successo di stare in questa
stanza dalle pareti chiare
e di pensare Ok cosa faccio
Come scappo da questa situazione
c'era una finestra e mi sono detta Ok
salto giù
forse sopravvivo mi rompo la gamba amen
poi mi sono guardata intorno
Cosa c'è qui forse ho paura a buttarmi
cosa ho attorno a me una penna uno
stivale
niente di letale
niente che possa ammazzarlo in un bagno
di sangue e allora ho detto sì
quello è uno stupro Ok ci siamo
ho detto sì
a me è successo
se sei donna Questo può succedere
immaginate di camminare per strada di
notte e di sentire dietro di voi una
voce che vi dice Ehi dove sta andando
passi pesanti che ti seguono Provate a
immaginare
l'ho sentita
sono crepe del suono vediamo così
come un urlo un piatto che si rompe un
incidente d'auto sono quei rumori che ti
costringono alla lucidità ti costringono
a valutare a valutare l'idea di poter
essere in pericolo
a me è successo e se sei donna può
succederti abbiamo parlato di vere
violenze Ok come se ci siano delle
violenze più importanti e altre di
minore importanza meno vera
Queste sono tutte vere violenze
ma se vi dicessi di pensare alla
violenza per eccellenza
quando parliamo di questioni di genere
che cosa mi direste
il femminicidio perché la violenza la
vediamo solo quando c'è sangue solo
quando ci sono lividi
tutte quelle volte in cui vivi della
violenza e il sangue non c'è
Allora forse la violenza non esista
io agognato il volto come fatto io lo
agognavo perché volevo quella bruttezza
Volevo il volto come fatto purché la mia
violenza esistesse
ci chiamano Survivor capite io per tutta
la vita mi sono descritto ma
sopravvissuta Ma che la violenza allo
stupro alla condivisione non consensuale
di video sessualmente espliciti cioè
pensate quanto Siamo stronzi abbiamo
dato alle donne una coccarda per essere
ancora viva Brava Sono sopravvissuta
Io però non voglio sopravvivere e
soprattutto non è vero che sono
sopravvissuta perché sono morta il fatto
che non ci sia la morte così come la
riteniamo vera Ok senza respiro non
significa
che io sia più in vita ok
lo Stato La polizia gli uomini
forgiano ogni giorno questa cultura
ma c'è una variabile che non abbiamo
considerato
le parole
le parole per noi sono sempre qualcosa
da mettere da parte Sì ma che cazzo ce
ne fotte delle parole che ce le facciamo
delle parole sono sempre cose secondarie
cose che come abbiamo detto non c'è
sangue quindi niente ferite
abbiamo normalizzato cose come stai
zitta
ma quello non era uno stupro potevi dire
di no ignora
ci siamo raccontati veramente queste
cazzate capite
abbiamo reso le parole quotidiane una
violenza incredibile
Chissà se me lo unisce sente Io lo
auguro lo auguro
perché questo stato che ci vuole morte
non solo gli uomini
non solo gli uomini la polizia le
istituzioni le leggi
ecco
quando si parla di parole
a noi donne viene recriminato il fatto
di usurparle
ogni volta che parliamo ci viene
rimproverato di essere pesanti e allora
oggi il mio aderirete perché io sarò la
persona più pesante che avrete mai
ascoltato e va bene così Sono una di
quella a cui si augura lo stupro ed
educativo così almeno stai tranquilla
ok E il mio direte mi va bene così
quando parliamo di parole alle donne
vengono tolte continuamente
perché perché si pensa che non abbiano
così tanto da dire da dover sapere
argomentare
alle donne si racconta che uno stupro
non lo puoi chiamare stupro lo devi
chiamare brutte esperienza sessuale ma
quando lo chiami stupro valuti via dello
stupro elabori L'idea dello stupro e dai
a quelle parole il peso che meritano
stupro misoginia violenza Ok sono parole
che dobbiamo dire perché non sono parole
usurpate usurate le parole non si
usurano se le usiamo spesso e
soprattutto se usiamo quelle giuste
le parole per le donne sono sempre
qualcosa di preso in prestito Vabbè oggi
le uso domani chissà perché le donne
abbiamo insegnato che si deve fare
silenzio è vero di più abbiamo inventato
la violenza di genere abbiamo inventato
la cultura dello stupro affinché loro
siano zitte
non importa che tu mi metta un cazzo nel
culo una lama in pancia non importa
L'importante è che io stia zitta perché
torniamo sempre alle parole la violenza
di genere la cultura dello stupro e la
cultura misogina
vogliono il nostro silenzio torniamo
sempre alle parole capire abbiamo
inventato tutto sto casino perché
abbiamo temuto che le donne potessero
aprire bocca
E allora oggi dobbiamo non solo aprire
la bocca dobbiamo fare pace con l'idea
che ne uccide più la lingua perché è
vero si può morire
ma ogni giorno Chi la vive questa
violenza ogni giorno noi e chi paga lo
scotto di questa merda noi E chi è che
non se ne occupa lo stato io chiedo allo
stato di occuparsi di un problema che
non riconosce come tale Come posso
chiedere allo stato di coprirmi le
spalle se non reputa il problema della
violenza di genere un problema
non mi credete Siamo circondati e
circondati da questa merda giornali
Sì lei rideva però dice che era uno
stupro
perché basta una risata per dire di sì
ma non basta mai un No per dire di no a
fianco alla faccia di lei la faccia di
lui
mentre si baciano meglio
bellissima neo mamma uccisa perché non
ci interessa della vita della donna ci
interessa che sia scopabile o che sia
madre perché noi sessualizziamo anche le
donne morte
Questa è violenza giornalistica di
genere e non la possiamo più accettare
televisione eh Ma esiste la libertà di
espressione questo politica li correct
Sì solo che parliamo di libertà di
espressione quando alle donne non è
concesso lo stesso spazio che è concesso
agli uomini Dov'è la controparte
io non me ne faccio un cazzo della
Libertà d'espressione se no non gli
spazi in cui parlare lo capite
violenza televisiva di genere è una
pedagogia Popolare che insegna che la
controparte non ci interessa che ne
possiamo fare a meno
la politica vuoi abortire sei un
assassina
lavori con il sesso Fai la [ __ ] [ __ ]
io non voglio più accettare questa merda
che sia chiaro
basta
Io non so fare grandi cose ma so parlare
e so per certo che ad ogni donna e ad
ogni persona perché non bastano le donne
debba essere insegnata l'arte della
retorica non dobbiamo voltarci
dall'altra parte perché è un problema
che ci riguarda tutti e tutte Dobbiamo
iniziare a parlare
ok perché non c'è nessun argomentazione
misogina che non sia comprensibile a noi
A me non interessa che mi capiate
perché la differenza fra chi ignora
volutamente E chi ascolta Senza capire è
l'indifferenza
Questa è una dichiarazione di guerra non
so se è chiaro È una dichiarazione di
guerra
e non avrete pace finché respirerò
perché io mi chiamo Valeria fonte e sono
una Ok che ha iniziato a parlare ma non
sarò l'ultima
non sarò l'ultima e finché respiro lo
giuro
non avrete pace
Noi siamo pronte
veniteci a cercare
[Applauso]